en los juegos olímpicos algunos eventos
tienen muchas rondas de competencia uno
de ellos es la prueba de 100 metros de
brazada de dorso varonil la gráfica de
punto superior muestra los tiempos en
segundos de los mejores 8 finalistas en
la ronda semifinal de las olimpiadas del
2012 la gráfica de puntos inferior
muestra los resultados de los mismos 8
nadadores pero en la ronda final qué
información podemos obtener de estas
gráficas veamos en la ronda semifinal
vemos que estos son los 8 tiempos de los
8 nadadores vemos 3 nadadores que
terminaron exactamente en 53.5 segundos
vemos un nadador que terminó en 53
puntos
siete segundos justo aquí y otro
narrador que está aquí termino en 52
puntos
siete segundos podemos pensar en muchas
cosas para cada uno de estos puntos
ahora en la ronda final un nadador fue
mucho mucho más rápido entonces este es
un 50 y 2.2 segundos mientras que este
nadador de aquí fue más lento no sabemos
qué punto fue aquí arriba pero sin
importar qué punto fue aquí arriba este
punto tomó más tiempo que cualquiera de
estos puntos así que su tiempo
definitivamente fue peor este es de 53
puntos 6 78 segundos 53.8 segundos
entonces veamos las opciones de
respuesta y veamos cuáles aplican los
nadadores tuvieron en promedio tiempos
menores en la ronda final en la final es
esto verdad tiempos menores en la final
en promedio
si vemos en la ronda final que está aquí
podemos tomar cada uno de estos puntos
sumarlos y dividirlos entre ocho el
número de tiempos que tenemos
pero veamos si podemos intuir por dónde
estará el promedio porque realmente solo
estamos comparando comparando estamos
comparando estas dos gráficas estas dos
distribuciones podríamos decir entonces
veamos si todos los datos fueran estos
tres puntos y estos tres puntos
podríamos encontrar podríamos intuir que
la media podría estar por esta zona
alrededor de 53.2 o 53.3 segundos más o
menos por aquí y ahora tenemos este
punto y este punto y si encontramos el
punto medio entre este punto y este
punto la mitad entre estos dos puntos
este punto te llevaría por esta zona y
el punto medio de estos dos puntos nos
movería hacia abajo un poco el punto
medio más o menos y digo otra vez no
estoy encontrando el número exacto tal
vez éste estará alrededor de 53.2
simón de 3.1 53.2 segundos
y esa es mi intuición para el promedio
de la ronda final
y ahora veamos el promedio de la ronda
semifinal
entonces si solo vemos si solo vemos
sólo veamos a estos cinco puntos de
abajo si encontramos el promedio podemos
intuir que se encontrará tal vez
alrededor al rededor de este punto algo
cercano a 53 puntos ronda de tres puntos
que es esto
hicimos de 3.3 segundos y ahora tenemos
todos estos que son 53.5 segunda y 3.3
que moverán al promedio incluso más
arriba entonces creo que es justo decir
que el punto medio en la ronda final
para el tiempo es menor que el punto
medio aquí arriba pueden calcular
ustedes pero yo sólo estoy tratando de
ver las distribuciones y utilizar la
intuición aquí y al menos en este caso
se puede ver bastante claro que los
nadadores tienen un promedio de tiempo
más bajo en la ronda final les tomo
menos tiempo
uno de los nadadores fue descalificado
en la ronda final bueno pues esto no es
real tenemos ocho nadadores en la ronda
semifinal y tenemos ocho nadadores en la
ronda final entonces esa no es verdadera
los tiempos en la ronda final varían
notablemente más que los tiempos en la
semifinal
eso parece ser cierto podemos ver en la
semifinal que muchos tiempos se
repitieron justo aquí sino de 3.3
segundos 53.5 segundos el tiempo alto no
es tan alto como este tiempo el tiempo
más bajo no es tan bajo como el de acá
entonces la ronda final definitivamente
definitivamente varía más
individualmente todos los nadadores
nadaron más rápido en la ronda final que
la semifinal
bueno eso no es cierto esté claramente
era alguno de los datos de aquí arriba
este punto tomó más tiempo que
cualquiera de los de arriba entonces
este representa a una persona que le
tomó más tiempo en la ronda final que lo
que le tomó en la semifinal
lo tenemos correcto